hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast cancer chemotherapy and
the tools needed to advantage treatment
in medical diverse population presented
by Jenny Williams she is an associate
professor at Stony Brook University with
a primary appointment in the Department
of family population and preventive
medicine and a secondary appointment in
the Department of Medicine
I am Marjorie Torrance of libraries and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
laberd's laberd's is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and lovers
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window in type your
questions into the box that appears on
the screen also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the windows just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button and the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Jimmy Williams I will now turn the
presentation over chair thank you very
much for the opportunity to talk to you
today my research interest in the area
of cancer chemoprevention cancer
chemotherapy with an emphasis on the
epigenetic and genetic differences that
is associated migration health disparity
today what I'm going to do is give you
an overall overview of my initial
research ventures how I actually got
into cancer racial health disparity
through the backdoor cancer
chemoprevention
really general background information
statistical challenges associated with
some racial health disparity and I'll
end this by talking about results
research results specifically research
models and I'll make analysis that I'm
interested and working on so to begin
our group is interested in studying
factors associated with initiation and
progression of a number of cancer but
photometry colon cancer colon cancer is
a great model for prevention at the time
from the from benign to metathesis to be
anywhere from 10 to 15 years
therefore intervention can result in
increased survival our early studies
involved looking at kind of preventive
and chemotherapeutic agents as far as
efficacy safety and mode of action so an
early observation noted that aspirin and
other NSAIDs prevented colorectal cancer
melanoma this is also chief esophageal
gastric breath and pranky erotic cancer
the problem with these agents for that
the efficiency was less than 50% and the
side effects was extensive
therefore our group wanting to enchance
the properties of NSAIDs but decrease
the fat effects develop these
derivatives we have a number of
derivatives that we study in the lab
this is just an example of a couple of
them they're basically in phase attached
to a spacer which is linked to an active
group so without going through any of
the experiments I'm basically going to
give you the facts of what we found and
it's in these facts are that these
derivatives the efficiency is higher
than their parent compound the effective
install connecticut artosis they
basically increased cell proliferation
and induced apoptosis
they're highly effective and safe and
animal models
and they exactly expect some several
Simeon factors particularly what I was
interested in in and was investigating
with NF kappa-b and beta catenin and p53
however the problem that I faced when I
did my study and this problem is faced
by a lot of other scientists that these
initial studies were conducted in
Caucasian American cancer cell lines
leaving out a huge population of
african-americans and Hispanics what is
the problem - what are the limitations
of the studies that are being done now
if the availability of racially diverse
tissues for research purposes the lack
of the existence of an African American
colorectal cancer cell life PD X's and
organize PD actions of patient-derived
xenograft and we all talk about
denominator as well so we need these
models in order to accept in vitro
studies as well as in vivo studies okay
so you can give you a background of how
I got into this research I initially
received I was initially received my
funding by k1 award under the Cure
program which is under the umbrella of
the chance of the center to reduce
cancer racial health disparities even
though I wasn't doing racial health
disparity at the time I attended
mandatory needed workshops but actually
included individuals that were working
in cancellation health disparity do you
need a direction and just going to the
meetings I was able to get a grasp of
what was what was needed in the area of
cancer racial health disparity and I was
able to actually define a project that
included
cancellation health disparity as well as
looking at human therapeutics and
looking at genetic differences so an
accepted fact is that african-americans
have the highest death rates from all
campus sites combined and from
malignancies of the lung colon rectum
breast prostate and the cervix of all
racial groups in the United States we
know that the burden of cancer is more
acute for racial and ethnic minority we
were in detailed assessment of to a
therapeutic agent and he clinical trials
like [ __ ] and respect to diversity we
also know that campus that differential
racial and ethnic population respond
differently between a therapeutic agents
so the general minorities are in poor
health the experience more significant
problems with justing care they're more
likely to be uninsured they're more
often receive lower quality health care
than other other Americans so what are
the causes of these inequities some of
them are culture bias are seem to be
culture bias with communication lack of
trust and social economic disparity
specifically barriers to high quality
cancer prevention and lacking early
detection so there are correlations that
we have noted in incidence and mortality
from colorectal cancer and these
correlations are age sex race and
ethnicity 90% of the new cases the
Nanticoke percent of deaths occur in
individual 50 and older differences are
likely between ethics between males and
females as far as gender related
differences affects the incidence and
mortality rates between men and women 30
to 40 percent higher for men than for
women and as I stated before colorectal
cancer is highest in African American
men and women compared to any other race
and this incidence rates could be 20%
higher and mortality rates 45 percent
higher so interestingly in New York the
state of New York
the incident rate for African
higher than any other group
however the mortality rate is not the
incident rate is higher not significant
however the rate of mortality is higher
but highly significant compared to any
other race if you look at Sussex County
are just a small area Long Island you
will see that the disparity differs from
region to region within the small within
a small region for example it is easier
but if not easier but it's the race of
colon cancer is better for females
compared to males living in suffix
counter arms early birth but this is
inversed when you go to a Miller's place
which is right down the street
overall the incident rate for colorectal
cancer in Suffolk County is not
significant between any of the races so
when you look at the mortality rate
it increases for african-americans both
fields females and males this slide only
is reiterate what I've been saying
before and which is that the incidence
rates of colorectal cancer its highest
for african-american male and female so
is mortality compared to other racial
groups and it's interesting to note that
this disparity is even higher is even
lower for other economic distress
individuals such as Hispanics or ages or
any other racial groups or ethnic groups
overall there's a 30% to 50% higher rate
of disease specific mortality after
diagnosis among african-american in
relationship to Caucasian even though
great progress that have been made in
understanding tumor biology and response
to treatment a month
non-hispanic Caucasian comfortable
knowledge for African Americans and
Hispanic population of years I'm not
sure if such as a focus but this is a
study that demonstrated that after
vectoring for treatment modality and
stage at time of treatment the disease
overall survival at five years and ten
years
post-surgery observed in
african-american patients with
colorectal cancer may not be attributed
to tumor stage our diagnosis diagnosis
or treatment but may be due to
differences and other biological and
genetic characteristics and this is
between African American patients and
Caucasian patients so we respect how do
we address racial health disparity I was
doing it these two methods one is
education and wanted research education
we need to increase equipment intentions
of underrepresented minorities citizens
in survive building a diverse population
of scientists and clinical investigators
therefore we have diverse thinking the
diverse study choices in respect to
research we must be corporate models
that span diverse population and use
these models to address biological
differences such as responses in attempt
unique ages differences in genetic and
immediate kinetics and as well as
looking at things like diet and what our
profile about microbiota is in the gut
and using this model we can me can lead
us to develop biomarkers that we can use
for early detection therapeutic targets
a prediction of pharmacological
responses
but what do we know what we do know is
that african-american patient's of
colorectal cancer have unique
polymorphisms in the PT PT tumor
suppressor which are linked to advanced
colorectal cancer this is at a meal
called some allele 72 and it's usually
an arginine but in vision in African
Americans there's a propensity to have a
protein in faith and pace of the IgE
there are more secondhand microlight
microsatellite instability and there are
distinct mutations and mismatch repair
genes so how does this affect me and how
does it play into what I'm studying
patron a3 and mismatch repair as well as
microsatellite instability mediate
defective T or therapeutic and chemo
preventive agents and difference between
african-americans and Caucasian
Americans and ways that are critical to
their function I compared to other
conservation african-american response
team of ravenna patients specifically
the chemo preventive effect of NSAIDs
have been shown to be population
dependence so one other factor is that
plays a role in Reichle health
disparities is that African Americans
with colorectal cancer has a
predominance of right-sided proximal to
it so what does this mean basically when
you have a colonoscopy
it's easy to go into where you go into
through the anus and travel along the
site of the colon here this is our the
right side of the other of the colon
it is difficult at point it's um
sometimes it's difficult to actually
catch
tumors that develop on the side of the
sub as a colon and when you have a
sigmoidal which is sometimes prescribed
this results in not being able to big
model actually end around in this area
so if you have a big model you
actually don't get to see what is
occurring at this dance
so the general consensus is that the
contribution to disparity is
socioeconomic status and access to poor
health however we do know that after
your gesture these determinants are
determinate disparity often persist
therefore other underlying factors such
as gene regulation is involved so this
is actually a model in which you're
trying to basically give a simplistic
answer to what's going on and basically
what we are trying to define here is
that there are factors such as diet and
environment which is influenced by
socioeconomic status that changes the
microbiota and the microbes that are in
your gut that results in increase in
epigenetics and increase in genetic
differences so that you are more prone
to go to a progression our initiation
into Cora cancer so this these changes
in genetic and epigenetic
actually results in Uncle J's being
increased and tumor suppressors being
decreased so uncle gene and two it's the
process of what are driving the
colorectal cancer so some associated
factors to colorectal cancer is a
genetic and genetic differences or
changes which are inherent or could be
acquired and it could be acquired
through diet ocular the environment
thought through the profile of
microbiota which is what our model is
trying to get so in our lab what we are
doing if you're using some sequencing
questionnaire and we are looking at
micro nutrient levels in the serum to
assess diet and diet differences between
people between races and after separate
groups we're also looking at
environmental and social
specifically meeting the metadata from
their charts in order to assess speeds
like diabetes obesity age sex similar
location and stage just the name of fear
and we also do studies when we're
looking at the profile of the microbiome
and we're doing this new DNA sequencing
of the 16s ribosome
a few years ago there was a study that
compares the diets of African American
and African from South Africa South
Africa has a lower rate of colon cancer
than african-american tear podiatrists
switch between groups resulting in a
reciprocal change in the coastal
biomarkers of cancer risk and an aspect
of the microbiota and my medical own
known to affect cancer risk
therefore this study basically shows
that one factor or one huge factors of
differences in diet which we know exist
between ethnic or racial groups so our
research approach is to use
retrospective and prospective tissues
such as spective editions that have been
collected years ago fixed and story
prospective tissue or tissues that we
acquire as surgeries being done so we
are collecting teachers from
african-american contagious and
Hispanics the isolate RNA DNA and
protein and we do ohmic analysis on them
I may speak
looking at the whole RNA genome near
looking at micro RNA and looking at DNA
methylation we look at poor dynamics
within a protein profile it's excellent
speakers in looking at those RNAs are
expressed and we're looking at 16s RNA
sequencing specifically for the
microbiota so as I said before our
limitation is not having tissues are 2d
study and so for one of our process is
to actually develop our own tissues but
problem that I had initially setting up
this project is that I live in Suffolk
County and the population in Suffolk
County is predominantly Caucasian about
the slide shows about eighty nine
percent of the city's more than 95% so I
had to create collaborations with other
individuals outside of Stony Brook area
and this has allowed me to amass a
number of patients from frozen and fresh
and some formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded which are so us issues
that have been fixed so so you can do
later studies with them my main source
Tricia acquisition is the co-operative
human tissue area network which is a
part of NIH and downstate which is a
part of the SUNY system really being
fully Browns State University in New
York okay so we have already gone over
this basically the Tisch to profess
perspective tissues
I make cell lines out of I made pd axes
and organize and I do the ohmic analysis
so I'm going to go over some of the
prospective tissue person and you're
golden you know on this so we collect
metadata for our sample and really to
lead but they're more than just ones
listed here sex age and stage this way
we're able to collect our samples and
organize our study in a way that we are
comparing apples apples and oranges
oranges so the first round line that we
developed are established for our
studies were xenograph
that were some tissue that was obtained
from an african-american female to
Fayetteville if we acquired it from the
co-operative magician that rustling
called it CT nf6 be felt here in this
big
what you see is that the cell lines that
we generated were to agenda Caen in life
or to a gimmick in life and they had the
morphological theater type of colonic
cells and this is an image just showing
how we've kept them growing in culture
and it's been going across culture for
what it really is not so they're well
established first we since the creation
or generation of the HTML 6 we have
established two additional
african-american cell line SP 501 and SB
521 this slide basically shows the
agency stating showing morphology of the
cells TM TM assailing basically shows
the internal organization of themselves
and karyotyping is used to actually look
at the chromosome numbers so we also
interrogate out our my characterization
characterizing ourselves we interrogate
the usual suspects those genes that are
involved in cancer progression
initiation and progression so we've
looked at a number of different proteins
and compared them to 1829 which is a
Caucasian cell line this image is
basically the same as before except the
business and share of a Western blot
analysis this is a miracle essence
looking at basically the same culprit
involved in Rochelle but involved in
colon cancer initiation and progression
I would like to point out here right now
the p53 if you look across here you if
you look across you would see that the
p53 itself the protein
cumulate in the cytoplasm I'm excuse me
in the nucleus this is an indication of
mutation within the p53 when it
accumulates like this in the nucleus so
one of the things that we're interested
in is p53 because teachers degree
affects
chemoprevention he must've entered
agents from being effective as well as
increases well being a part of racial
health disparity and in fact when we
look at c18064 sequencing we found that
it had picked the gene pro pro mutation
at the allele 72 I mentioned earlier
though because we want to know how these
cells behave act when we treat them with
cupid's therapeutic agents we did a
panel of agent this is just a
representation of this a few that we
looked at and in most cases because
african-american cell lines for
basically less effective well the agents
were less effective against the
african-americans Allies didn't work for
the Caucasian cells here we're using two
commercially available Caucasian so on
the only exception here that we saw was
for sulindac which actually isn't one of
the compounds that we formulated but we
saw that with Fiat piano six and not the
others but this is piano fixed there was
a full an egg itself was more effective
than it was against the ht3 annihilation
Yvonne 1:6 so also what was in important
for us to see was that factoring
yourself which is a FDA approved drug
for colon cancer had no effect
whatsoever against our african-american
cell
at the highest concentration examines in
fact farthest yourself had a stimulating
effect when you look at when you did
this in vivo in an animal model so you
can see here at the practice course you
know cinematix tumor growth so the other
thing that we are doing is creating
organoid and all the noise are actually
important new models that have come out
within the last few years for and
they're very important for assessing
chemotherapeutic agents because they
actually have more of an architecture
that is similar to the tissue to the
tumor tumor itself than having cell line
so we went to John Hopkins University
and was trained in order to grow these
organized this is an image our own
organoid we've only done one so far took
us a quite a bit of time to actually get
all the reagents together
it's a intricate process but once you
get everything together you can actually
start smelling within your process but
with generating August which is now what
we where we are we have gotten
everything organized to the point where
we can actually call them continually in
our lab so today we have gotten agree we
have established three african-american
fellows we have five count on Caucasian
American PD Xers three african-american
PD X's three Hispanic PD X's and one :
organoid and we use something tandem
disease it's an assay in order to test
to see whether or not we have any
genetic variation between
our tissues and the last passage of our
cell lines PD axes are organized the PD
axes patient-derived xenograft they are
basically developed from there generated
from efficient discard the basic unit a
small chunk of the tissue and I'll
actually insert it under the standard
server in near mice and within a month
they developed into salt enough I'm
interview DX's our xenograph anything--i
graphs are actually architectural more
closely associated with the human tissue
or the human tumor than the mouth spend
the v zilla graph that we make
themselves so the advantages over cell
lines are disadvantages on the cell line
it cost is more cost-effective to use
cell lines it's more cost effective to
use pd axes than all the noise the
organized in the TDX have more realistic
my credit anatomy
so you actually seeing what's going on
basically real time our realistically
closer and related than the cell as
himself they're more active able
accurately predicts penises and organize
more equity ridiculous the efficacy of
few therapeutic agents so our basic goal
is to generate a database that would
make the same sample set to the ohmic
analysis for economics RNA seek DNA
methylation and look at
microbiota the giant and using meta data
to assess what differences exist on
Association homage status bases and also
using in vitro in vivo models that we
are generating and lab to actually
assess these forming analysis in a
clinical setting our preclinical setting
so what we're doing right now is we're
doing find a seat and exon exon speak
using a core facility at Cold Spring
Harbor Laboratory we also looking at DNA
methylation easy hosting our
laboratories as well and we're doing
microbiota from research consortium in
Colorado and it's collaborating with us
so the genomic analysis I'm moving just
a step further just to give you an
overview of some of the stuff that we
have found and associated with my name
Mike Ronnie and methylation as it
compares to african-americans and
Caucasians so before we start I would
just like to say that micro rna's are
non-coding RNA they basically are there
specifically regulatory RNAs their
process as instant as there are large
units and transported out of the nucleus
into the cytoplasm where their process
to the point where they become mature
micro rna's I mean mature micro RNA
binds to G prime untranslated region of
the messenger RNA and depending on how
tightly they die they can repress
translation or they can send the micro
RNA for degradation so the first thing
we did was look at Michael I made
differences using micro RNA microarray
this first slide here just shows the
difference between tumor versus parent
adjacent normal colon tissue we saw
something like 49 million employees down
regulated micro RNA when you look at
phone changes of too much normal when we
compared
african-americans to Caucasians we were
able to find five
microRNAs that had a weight or tumor
effect and by doing qualitative rt-pcr
we are actually able to validate these
microRNAs one of them of interest of
being near 182 Amir 183 so near 183 182
our uncle years and they belong to a
family of transcription factors or
transcription micron a repertory micro
RNA and they doubt the downstream
targets of near 182 and 183 Fox of 1 and
Fox open each voxel 1 apart for 3 a
suppressor protein and we were able to
sure an inverse correlation between the
up regulation of near 182 and 118 and
down regulation of Fox or one at Fox or
three the differences were seen to be
significant when you look bad
normal versus tumor the difference was
there were slight differences when you
look at african-americans compared to
Caucasians but these were not considered
to be significant we also looked at Pro
dynamics this is a map for dynamics in
which we looked at differences between
normal and tumor african-american and
Caucasian and we compared them together
and outside looking at African American
African Americans normal in tumor and
Caucasians to Caucasian normal tumor and
then compared those factors Caucasians
and african-americans what is it what we
are trying to now dig more deeply into
are the differences that we see in the
tumor of the African American and the
Caucasian
we also looked at gene regulation even
RNA seek and this actually this shows
the differences with colorectal cancer
tor and adjacent normal a number that
were upregulated and numbers that were
down regulated we also looked at the
differences between african-american
Caucasian and looked at those that were
regulated and those that were down
regulate this is just a slide that shows
different genes that were upregulated in
different genes that were down regulated
we actually are still assessing what all
of this means we have like a few of
genes and you just trying to assess how
what role they play in champ initiation
as where as well as racial health
disparities we also looked at
methylation so as you know G's can be
controlled by upstream methylation at
promoter region so we compared this in
african-americans and Caucasians as well
and this slide basically shows the total
methylation and those that are -
methylated and those that are hyper
methylated and African Americans that
had colorectal cancer and in Caucasians
that had correct the cancer so from that
slide we were able to deduce that
African Americans had 1588
hypermethylated and 100 - methylated
differentially methylated regions and
inculcation was 109 hyper methylated and
for - methylated DMR's this represents
the 14:26 fall and a 25 sole difference
respectively so what we are trying to
assess now is
what does this need a lot of the
hypermethylation were not necessarily in
promoter region so if it's interesting
to see that there is this much of a
difference in methylation even if it
isn't in a gene are associated with the
club promoter other needs so also what
was interesting is that one of the genes
that were differentially mentioned
methylated between African Americans
Pima businessman decent normal was kill
one which is a pure suppressor and this
actually this gene is also actually down
regulated by meal 182 which kind of
showed that 15 silence land reclamation
as well as the up regulation of near 182
may also affect its it's being expressed
so what we have found is that we have a
micro RNA profile that you know 1893 she
expressed micro RNA normal stress is
tumor we have validated significant
differences in the expression level 5
micron days between Caucasian Americans
and African Americans right quantitative
PCR was a significant main effects of
racing tumor we also have performed
community chemistry analysis samples
showing an inverse correlation between
expression in the air one ATP and a
level of service to thicken target
protein
dr. Lyon faculty a they showed unique
polymorphism I don't discuss especially
unique problem offices and typically due
to your suppresses atactic America's a
tiny officer may see it specifically
done this is one of our cell lines which
is also a filament are chiral phenotypes
we are differentially methylated
profiles generated by Luna 2 versus
normal as well african-americans were
six occasions
you're guilty and charges are three
african-american cell on the Hispanics
on the african-american so PDX isn't
three Hispanic three african-americans
and five Caucasian PD active this will
provide us with models which can respond
to a convention and chemotherapy
so overall the goal of our research is
requires Americ bridge netic American
expenses and provide details and they
assist in the development of key event
pages that will stand a red carnation I
would like to emphasize that our
research is not exclusive and it's
inclusive we're interested in what
creates cancer what causes cancer to
progress and in all races and all
ethnicities there are a number of people
who I thank me to thank who've been
great collaborators there at Stony Brook
University there at Moffitt Cancer
Center there at Wash U University and
SUNY Downstate as well as Cold Spring
Harbor and the University of Colorado I
thank you for your attention thank you
dr. Williams for that informative
presentation if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the green joining button at the
lower left of the presentation window
type your questions into the box that
appears on your screen and click on the
send button
dr. Williams we'll be following up with
all of your questions via email I would
also like to think I would also like to
take waggery I respect to once again
thank dr. Jeanne alarms for her
presentation I would also like to thank
laberd's for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through January of 2017 you'll receive
an email from Margaret's letting me know
in this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcements
with their colleagues who may have
missed today's live set that's all for
now thank you for joining us and we hope
to see you again soon goodbye